اعتبر وزير الدفاع البريطاني ااا بين
والاس ان انسحاب القوات الروسيه من خيرسون
يمثل فشلا استراتيجيا اخر لروسيا وقال ولص
في بيان النخيرسون كانت الهدف الرئيسي
الوحيد الذي استولت عليه روسيا وانسحابها
منها لابد ان يتساءل الشعب الروسي عن جدوى
هذه الحرب واضاف الوزير ان انسحاب روسيا
من خيرسون امر مرحب به ولم يقلل احد من
قدر التهديد المستمر الذي تمثله موسكو
واشار ونص الى ان اوكرانيا مستمره في
القتال بدعم من بريطانيا والغرب
قال جهاز الاستخبارات العسكريه البريطاني
ان خيرس كانت هي العاصمه الاقليميه
الوحيده التي استولت عليها القوه الروسيه
منذ شباط فبراير الماضي لذا فان انسحابها
منها الحق ضررا كبيرا بسمعه روسيا وتوقعت
الاستخبارات البريطانيه ان تكون عمليه
الانسحاب قد بدات بالفعل في الثاني
والعشرين من شهر اكتوبر تشرين الاول
الماضي
وبالاضافه الى تطورات في خرس تشهد الجبهه
الشرقيه في اوكرا لتطورات الميدانيه
متلاحقه في ظل الاستمرار المحاولات
الاخرانيه لاستعاده مدن وبلدات جديده في
مقاطعه قال الانفصاليون المولون لروسيا
انهم يواصلون التقدم في محور مطار دنيتك
الدولي وانهم على وشك السيطره على بلده
بروميس جمال غربي المقاطعه في المقابل
ذكرت قياده الاركان الاخرانيه انها صدقت
ماني محاولات تقدم للقوات الروسيه على
محاور القتال في هذه المقاطعه بما في ذلك
محور بروميس
فقال الحاكم الاوكراني للمقاطعه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه استعاده السيطره على 11 بلده
منذ سبتمبر الماضي
بسبب الالغام التي زرعتها القوه الروسيه